الممثله التي لم ترغب بالكشف عن اسمها
اعربت عن دهشتها لما يجري حاليا وقالت ان
منتج الفيلم كذب
عليها فالممثل استجابت لدعوه التمثيل في
فيلم تجري احداثه قبل نحو 2000 عام وحمل
انذاك اسم فرسان
الصحراء انت تجدين نفسك اليوم وسط كابوس
حقيقي هذا ما وجدت نفسي
[موسيقى]
فيه في عالم لطالما صليت من
اجله اصلي الى الله ليساعدني
[موسيقى]
ف فالقتل ليس الاسلوب
الصحيح وفي الدور الذي مثلته هذه السيده
اطلق على الرسول محمد اسم جورج ولقبته
الشخصيات الاخرى بالمعلم او الوالد المعلم
وليس باسم محمد وقد حصلت الممث على 500
دولار لبضع ايام عمل ولكنها تقول ان منتج
الفيلم وكاتبه سام باسيل كذب عليها بشان
المحتوى هذا ظلم خاصه لما حدث للقتلى
وعائلاتهم وقد اتصلت بباسل الذي لازال حتى
الان مسرا على افكاره حسب ما تقول طلب مني
تصريح لوسائل الاعلام بالقول اني تعبت من
قتل المسلمين للابرياء
ولا ترغب الممثله بالكشف عن اسمها لخوف
عائلتها عليها ولكنها هي ليست خائفه
الغضب والاذى ولكني لست
بخائف زوجي خائف من اجلي ولكني لست كذلك
انا غاضبه
جدا وقدمت الممثله اعتذارها للمسلمين
واكدت انها لو كانت على علم بما ستصل اليه
الامور لما قامت بتاديه
الدور